مشاهدينا على كل الناس نعود ونشير لهذا
الخبر العاجل الذي وردناه قبل قليل حول
العقد والاعلان الرسمي الان من نادي النصر
الانضمام كريستيانو رونالدو
رسميا ولمده موسمين مع النصر السعودي طبعا
رونالدو ارتبط اسمه
بعقد مع النصر في مباريات كاس العالم
وطبعا لم يتم التاكيد على هذه المعلومات
حتى هذه اللحظه التي نعلن فيها هذا الخبر
رونالدو جاء من مانشستر يونايتد وانها
تعاقده خلال
منافسه كاس العالم مع هذا النادي طبعا
مسيرته حافله جدا بداها في لشبونه انتقل
الى ايضا ريال مدريد وقبل ذلك مانشستر
يونايتد ومن ثم ريال مدريد ثم يوفنتوس
وعاد الى مانشستر يونايتد الى ان قام باخر
مباراه همم في كاس العالم لم تكن بالنسبه
له همم مباراه همم جيده اذا مصحه تعبير
خرج باكن بعد الخساره التي مني بها ومنتخب
وطبعا في كاس العالم شاهدنا همم
رونالدو خسر وخاصه انه خسر امام منتخب
المغرب في تلك المباراه